acusación de complicidad en crímenes de
guerra el gigante petrolero francés
total Energy se encontró el viernes con
una causa judicial en la que se le acusa
de haber suministrado queroseno a las
tropas rusas en Ucrania el caso ha sido
presentado por dos ong la francesa
Darwin climas qualition y la ucraniana
grayson Winston acusan a total de seguir
explotando un yacimiento de gas
siberiano y de producir combustible para
las fuerzas aéreas rusas total energis
respondió calificando las acusaciones de
escandalosas y difamatorias así se lo
hizo saber al diario francés lemont
estas acusaciones contra Nuestra Empresa
que lleva a cabo sus operaciones
respetando estrictamente la política de
la Unión Europea y las sanciones
europeas en vigor son excepcionalmente
graves e infundadas Lemon ya había hecho
las mismas acusaciones en un reportaje
en agosto en septiembre total se
desprendió de su participación del 49%
en el grupo energético ruso
tierneptegatz que explota el yacimiento
de gas de ter la ministra francesa de
transición energética reconoció la
gravedad de las acusaciones
la justicia seguirá su curso ahora mismo
no conozco los entresijos de esta
demanda pero permítame ser muy claras
sería inaceptable que una empresa
francesa no respetara las sanciones y
cometiera crímenes de guerra lo que va
más allá de las sanciones
fue una de las empresas francesas que
siguieron operando en Rusia tras la
invasión de Ucrania el pasado febrero
otras de ellas el grupo alimentario
Danone anunció el viernes que iba a
poner fin a la mayor parte de sus
operaciones